also andere spiel ist auf deinen namen
onken cibak gekommen grüße aus
ingolstadt das zwei dokus in bauen also
früher habe ich mich zwieback genannt
weil ich musik und deutsch rap
insbesondere sehr beschissen fand und
ich dachte das muss sich ändern und
zwieback ist ja gegen schweißerei
deswegen habe ich gedacht ich nämlich
auf jedenfalls fieback außerdem spiegelt
zwieback etwas sehr trockenes wieder
etwas was für trockenen humor vielleicht
auch steht meine selbstironie und der
onkel ist in beinahe an den ich mir
verpasst hab weil man muss ja heute
eigentlich immer bei namen tragen so was
wie dj bla bla bla bla bla oder für mich
war ganz klar es muss deutsch sein also
der onkel
außerdem ist der onkel auch eine
respektsperson also könnte man sagen ich
bin eine selbstironische respektsperson
betroffenen humor die auf deutsch heißt
herr bahamut fragt werder wenn du die
erste frage im kanzlerduell hätte
stellen können wie hätte sie gelautet
frau merkel frau merkel ist fragt hallo
wer da was ist seine größte angst
ja es gibt wenige ängste die ich nicht
überwinden möchte deswegen verändert
sich die größe der angst ich hab aber
eine angst die bleibt nämlich dinge zu
verpassen also dinge wie den zug oder
die richtige gelegenheit das große los
oder was auch immer
und dann nachher sich unheimlich zu
ärgern dass man nicht zur richtigen zeit
am richtigen ort gewesen ist techno pro
geleitet fragt serdar somuncu wenn du
die zeit zurückdrehen könnte würde so
etwas anders machen und wenn ja was
liebe grüße aus zürich
ich würde nichts anders machen wenn ich
die zeit zurückdrehen könnte ich würde
vielleicht vieles sogar noch extremer
machen weil ich in meinem leben oft aus
meiner sicht sogar zu oft mir dinge hat
bieten lassen die man sich nicht bieten
lassen sollte fremdbestimmung
bevormundung ungerechtigkeit und dagegen
würde ich heute viel schneller angehen
auch mit dem risiko dass ich dafür
sanktioniert werden belegt sehr wohl
fragt frage an zelda wird die rolle des
hasses tatsächlich demnächst beendet
kann man auch obwohl du vielleicht
gerade weil du damit auf dem höhepunkt
bist klammer zu fragezeichen und wenn ja
was kommt danach
bei der razzia galt black werwolf ist
mitglied einer nationalen
untergrundbewegung der asias wird
sterben das steht fest so wie jeder
prophet irgendwann das zeitliche segnen
muss damit er zu einer lichtgestalt wird
zu einer ikone die nur noch in der
erinnerung bleibt
dieser zeitpunkt wird im frühjahr des
nächsten jahres 2014 irgendwann sein der
es hieß wird feierlich in den himmel
aufsteigen und dann vielleicht in
irgendeiner anderen form zurückkehren
fest steht aber auch dass als vor
spähtrupp sozusagen der politik die band
des kassiers zur sexy revolution
aufrufen wird ab oktober sexy revolution
and politics on tour